THE LAWLESS, DESTRUCTIVE RIOTS
SHAKING OUR NATION, OH, NO,
THOSE ARE KENTUCKY FANS, I'M
SORRY, AFTER LOSING,
THE LAWLESS -- NO, I'M
SORRY, THAT'S THE MICHIGAN FANS
AFTER WINNING, NO I AM SORRY,
THAT'S A PUMPKIN FESTIVAL
GONE AWRY, COME ON, THOSE ARE
KIDS JUST BLOWING OFF STEAM
WITH GOOD-NATURED ARSON. THERE
YOU GO! THAT'S THE WORRISOME,
LET'S CALL IT URBAN VIOLENCE WE
WERE LOOKING FOR.
>> IT HAS BEEN A NIGHT OF CHAOS,
VIOLENCE, LAWLESSNESS IN
BALTIMORE OVER THE
DEATH OF FREDDIE GRAY.
>> RIGHT NOW THE NATIONAL GUARD
IS ON THE SCENE TRYING TO
RESTORE PEACE AND AS WE SAID ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED
TODAY.
>> Jon: BUT -- AH, -- (BLEEP).
YOU KNOW WHAT? THAT'S PROBABLY
THE ONE TIME EVEN KIDS DON'T
EVEN WANT TO HEAR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT SCHOOL IS CLOSED.
HONEY, NO SCHOOL! YOU HAVE A
RIOT DAY.
JUST STAY IN YOUR PJS AND WATCH
YOUR FAVORITE CARTOONS.
BE PREEMPTED BY FOOTAGE OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD IN FLAMES.
YES, ONCE AGAIN THE COMBINATION
OF AN ECONOMICALLY STRUGGLING
INNER CITY, POLICE FORCE CHARGED
WITH KEEPING ITS CITIZENS OUT OF
EVERYONE ELSE'S VIEW HAS
COMBUSTED, LIKE WATTS AND
DETROIT IN THE SIXTIES, GEORGIA
IN THE SEVENTIES,
MIAMI IN THE EIGHTIES, L.A.
AND ST. PETERSBERG IN THE
NINETIES, THE CYCLICAL ERUPTIONS
APPEAR LIKE TRAGEDY CICADAS.
DEPRESSING IN THEIR SIMILARITY,
PREDICTABILITY AND
INTRACTABILITY, OR TO PUT THAT
ANOTHER WAY --
>> HARD TO BELIEVE.
THIS IS GOING ON IN A MAJOR
AMERICAN CITY RIGHT NOW, THIS IS
A SCENE THAT A LOT OF US NEVER
ANTICIPATED SEEING IN A CITY
LIKE BALTIMORE, HARD TO BELIEVE
THIS IS GOING ON AS I KEEP
SAYING IN A MAJOR AMERICAN CITY.
I DON'T REMEMBER SEEING
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA IN A LONG
TIME.
>> Jon: ELVIS LEADING A HERD
OF ORTHODOX JEWISH UNICORNS
THROUGH A CITY STREET, THAT
WOULD BE HARD TO BELIEVE.
THIS (BLEEP), THIS (BLEEP)
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
FERGUSON WAS JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO AND YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> IT IS HARD FOR ME TO BELIEVE
THAT IN THIS DAY AND AGE, 2014,
SO MANY YEARS AFTER DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT WE ARE SEEING NATIONAL
GUARD TROOPS ON THE STREET TO
PREVENT THIS KIND OF VIOLENCE IN
THIS DAY AND AGE, IT'S SOMETHING
I DIDN'T THINK WE WOULD
BE SEEING AGAIN.
>> Jon: I AM WORRIED ABOUT
YOU.
DO I NEED TO GET SANDLER TO GO
OVER TO YOUR HOUSE AND -- JUST
RUN (BLEEP) BY YOU EVERY
MORNING.
WELL LOOK, BLITZER MAY HAVE BEEN
TAKEN OFF GUARD BUT CERTAINLY
THE MAYOR OF BALTIMORE WOULDN'T
BE TAKEN OFF GUARD.
>> I HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
OUR GOVERNOR AND HE HAS AGREED,
AND I HAVE REQUESTED AND HE HAS
AGREED TO DEPLOY THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
>> WHEN THE MAYOR CALLED ME,
WHICH QUITE FRANKLY WE WERE GLAD
THAT SHE FINALLY DID, INSTANTLY
WE SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
>> Jon: OH, OH, OH.
WELL, ISN'T THE GOVERNOR A
LITTLE BIT PASSIVE AGGRESSIVE?
I MEAN I WAS THERE ALL
WEEKEND.
BY THE PHONE, BUT FINE, IF SHE
WANTS THE CITY TO BURN?
WHO AM I, I'M JUST A SIMPLE
GOVERNOR WITH EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE A STANDING
ARMY OF RESERVISTS?
BUT I GUESS CALLING THEM OUT
WOULD NOT BE ON FLEEK AS THE
YOUNG PEOPLE --
(LAUGHTER)
YOU MOTHER (BLEEP), YOU SWORE
THAT THAT'S A THING!
YOU SWORE THAT ON FLEEK WAS A
THING.
THEY SWORE TO ME. I SAID, ON
FLEEK?
AND THEY SAID, NO, THAT'S A
THING. I WAS LIKE --
I AM GOING TO (BLEEP) PUNT YOU
MOTHER (BLEEP).
I KNOW THAT'S A THING.
SO TO THE MAYOR WAS A LITTLE
LATE WITH HER EMERGENCY STATE
DECLARING.
WHEN SHOULD SHE HAVE DONE IT?
>> THERE IS A STATE OF EMERGENCY
AFTER A NIGHT OF VIOLENCE AND
CHAOS.
WAS BALTIMORE CAUGHT OFF GUARD?
>> THAT CALL SHOULD HAVE CAME IN
TWO OR THREE DAYS AGO.
>> WHY WAS THIS NOT IN PLACE
SATURDAY OR SUNDAY WHEN THE
SITUATION BEGAN?
>> Jon: WELL, SURE, NO, THEY
COULD HAVE DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN BALTIMORE ON
SUNDAY, MAYBE SATURDAY, OR MAYBE
SOMEWHERE IN THE 1970S.
AND THIS SEEMS TO INDICATE
THE ISSUE IN OUR CITY EMERGENCY
ALERT SYSTEM.
THERE APPEAR TO BE ONLY TWO
POINTS ON THE SCALE, NORMAL AND
ON FIRE.
EVEN VOLCANOES HAVE A FOUR
STEP WARNING SYSTEM.
IT DOESN'T GO FROM CLEAR SKY
TO, THE FLOOR IS LAVA! AND
CLEARLY BALTIMORE WAS BELCHING
SMOKE FAR BEFORE SATURDAY.
>> BALTIMORE'S POVERTY RATE IS
NEARLY DOUBLE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
>> AGAIN, THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
AMONG YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN
HOVERS AROUND 30 PERCENT.
>> HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
FOR BLACK MALES ARE
DEVASTATINGLY LOW.
>> A LACK OF ACCESS TO LABOR
MARKETS, HEALTH CARE, HOUSING.
>> HAS CHRONIC SEVERE DRUG AND
CRIME ISSUES.
>> ONE OF THE HIGHEST VIOLENT
CRIME RATES IN AMERICA.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW YOUR CITY IS
(BLEEP)ED UP WHEN IT IS LAST
MOST SUCCESSFUL EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM WAS CASTING EXTRAS FOR A
TELEVISION SHOW ABOUT HOW
(BLEEP) UP YOUR CITY IS.
AND WHEN GETTING ARRESTED -- AND
WHEN GETTING ARRESTED IS ONE OF
YOUR MORE RELIABLY LUCRATIVE
OPTIONS.
>> SINCE 2011, THE CITY OF
BALTIMORE HAS PAID OUT CLOSE TO
$6 MILLION IN COURT JUDGMENTS OR
SETTLEMENTS TO VICTIMS OF POLICE
ABUSE.
>> Jon: THE POLICE BRUTALITY
LOTTERY IS NOW $6 MILLION! ALL
YOU NEED IS A BROKEN
TAILLIGHT AND A DREAM.
AND TO THE POLICE'S DEFENSE,
HEY, IT'S (BLEEP) TRUE.
THEY PAID OUT $6 MILLION.
I DIDN'T MAKE THAT UP.
AND BY THE WAY, TO THE POLICE'S
DEFENSE, IT IS NOT REALLY THEIR
JOB TO FIX THE WHOLE MESS.
>> THIS HAS BEEN OUR RESPONSE TO
COMMUNITIES ASKING FOR
RESOURCES.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS ESSENTIALLY
BECOME A SURROGATE FOR JOBS,
HEALTHCARE, EDUCATION AND ALL
THE THINGS THESE COMMUNITIES
NEED TO BE HEALTHY.
>> Jon: IT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
MAYBE A MORE NUANCED ALERT
SYSTEM COULD ALLOW FOR MORE
PRODUCTIVE INTERVENTION BEYOND,
YOU HAVE TEN SECONDS TO
DISPERSE.
OR WE CAN AGREE TO KEEP IGNORING
THE ROOTS OF HOW SYSTEMICALLY
HISTORICALLY DISENFRANCHISED
MANY AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES STILL ARE ONLY
PAYING ATTENTION TO THEM
WHEN WE FEAR THEIR
FIERY BALL OF ANGER THREATENS
TO ENTER OUR AIRSPACE.
LIKE SOME KIND OF ALEX HALEY'S
COMET, AND ONCE AGAIN, BREATHING
A BLISSFUL SIGHT OF FORGETFUL
RELIEF WHEN IT IS ANOTHER NEAR
MISS.